deutschlandtempo brauchen neues
deutschlandtempo wird im Moment viel
erzählt erzählen wir uns auch
gegenseitig dass wir das auch wollen und
können Christian Böttgers bei uns der
wie weniger andere Auskunft geben kann
über den Zustand und das
deutschlandtempo der Deutschen Bahn er
wird gar was ist eigentlich aus ihrer
Sicht bei der Deutschen Bahn in den
letzten Jahrzehnten wirklich schief
gelaufen
also ich glaube man muss auch wieder bei
der Politik anfangen die Bahn die
Deutsche Bahn ist dann Unternehmen im
Bundesbesitz und der Bund als Eigentümer
hat sich sehr schlecht darum gekümmert
er hat sich wirklich sehr lustlos darum
gekümmert er hat das Unternehmen lange
Zeit machen lassen was es wollte das
Unternehmen hat sich selber seine
Strategie ausgedacht immer es gab nie
ein politischen Beschluss dafür dass
unser wir wollen ein internationaler
Logistikkonzern werden sondern die
Politik hat es mehr oder weniger Zähne
knirschen hingenommen dass der Vorstand
ist so geschlossen hat
und was heißt das dann international
Logistikkonzern was wo ist die Deutsche
Bahn überall unterwegs DDB hat heute ja
mehr als die Hälfte ihres Umsatzes im
Geschäften die nichts mit Eisenbahn in
Deutschland zu tun haben so der größte
Block ist immer die internationale
Logistik man macht also weinlogistik in
Australien minenlogistik in Südafrika
also wenn es darum geht wie kommt
wirklich der Wein von dem einzelnen
Weingut wie kommt der sozusagen ähm
irgendwo in den Hafen und wird dann also
versendet besser nachher in Hannover
dann im Regal steht
das organisiert also ein Schenker und
die Logistik für Minen dass man also
sagt die Leute brauchen irgendwas an ähm
an Zubehör an vor Materialien und das
fertige Raffinat was auch immer das dann
im Einzelfall ist das muss weg
transportiert werden das macht Schenker
das Schenker einer der großen Welt
der Deutschen Bahn und das ist eine
Tochtergesellschaft der Deutschen Bahn
und sozusagen auch der Steuerzahler
haftet sozusagen für die Risiken da drin
die letzten drei Jahre ist es sehr gut
gelaufen verschenken aber vorher war das
also immer dünne die haben immer weniger
Gewinne gemacht als die Wettbewerber was
macht die Deutsche Bahn noch das ja
hochinteressant ist man ist ja
europaweit aktiv im Bereich
Personenverkehr das heißt man betreibt
Busse in London
Rettungswagen
Notrufzentralen
ja auch Busverkehre regionalverkehre in
Kroatien das ist also das Geschäft von
arriba man hat jetzt ja etwa 30 Venture
capitalbeteiligung über die DDB
öffentlich so wenig wie möglich sagt
aber man will also Drohnen Flughäfen
bauen und ähm und also auch so Sachen
wie Birds oder sowas ist eine DB
Beteiligung
geht darum dass man sozusagen die ganze
Welt mit Stichwörtern irgendwo kartieren
kann das also nur drei Worte haben und
dann findet man also wenn man sagt lands
Fernsehen ZDF würde man diese Location
finden weltweit sozusagen
ich kenne die Details dazu nicht aber
also
groß Internet Startup und die sind also
da in vielen lustigen Unternehmen
beteiligt einige auch im
Mobilitätsbereich
stimmt es dass die Bahn auch Fahrräder
in Kopenhagen betreibt ich glaube ja ich
weiß nicht alles einzeln aber es könnte
dir sehr gut sein also offline
wenn die damit Geld verdienen würde ich
immer sagen Ja mach doch ja also vor
fünf Jahren hat
hat die DB und das hat die ganze Presse
auch geschrieben hat man gesagt arriba
sei die Ertragsperle das Konzerns also
das sind die die unter anderem die
Notrufzentralen und die Busse und
ähnliches machen ähm dann hat man
zwischendurch mal über eine Milliarde in
England verloren also nicht mit Corona
zusammenhängt sondern vorher
seither sagt das keiner mehr so laut
also seither machen die stetig Verluste
ähm aber
seit vielen Jahren ist das also lieber
ein Geschäft mit jemand anders fragen
wie viele aus wie vielen Gesellschaften
besteht eigentlich die Deutsche Bahn
sind irgendwie glaube ich 740 oder so
wobei ich 740 die Zahl ist gar nicht so
beeindruckend also wenn sie
international Logistik machen dann
müssen sie in jedem Land eine eigene
Bestform haben das muss so sein das ist
gut und richtig so und in China brauchen
sie sogar in jeder Provinz eine eigene
Gesellschaft und ähm also alleine aus
diesem Geschäft Schenker dass du mal
weltweit ist ergeben sich ich weiß nicht
250 Gesellschaften die braucht man aber
die Bahn hat auch hier Eisenbahngeschäft
in Deutschland und das halte ich für
viele bedenklicher
Eisenbahn in Deutschland auch dort hat
man viele Tochtergesellschaften
gegründet also das heißt bei der DB ist
es so dass die
Sicherheitskräfte die Reinigungskräfte
die IT ähm die Kommunikation die also
die zielanzeigen in den Bahnhöfen machen
die Sicherungsposten die also bei
Baustellen was machen das eigenes alles
eigene Gesellschaft und der muss
Ersatzverkehr das sind alles eigene
Gesellschaften jeweils mit drei
Geschäftsführern jeweils mit vielen
freigestellten Betriebsräten und es wird
ihm erzählt wenn Sie mit der Bahn
verhandeln dann kommen immer neuen DB
Leute von neuen verschiedenen
Gesellschaften die auch neuen
rivalisierende Ziele haben und sich dann
manchmal also auch mit ihnen streiten
untereinander also die DB hat eben auch
intern einen Strukturproblem weil das
sind gar nicht diese 740 Firmen sondern
ich glaube wenn man nur die Eisenbahn in
Deutschland sich anschaut dann sind okay
zwei Sachen wenn wir da hinten diese
ganzen weichen da auch sehen ne ich habe
eine interessante Zahl gehört stimmt ist
dass wir die Weichen von ungefähr
130.000 auf 60.000 oder so reduziert
haben ja also ich kenne das nicht so
aber ich halte es für absolviert also
man warum hat den letzten Jahren das
letzte massiv zurückgebaut
man musste natürlich Geld sparen und das
hängt auch mit Signaltechnik zusammen
mit neu Signaltechnik ist es so dass
jeder weichen Anschluss Geld kostet da
wurde also noch mal gefragt brauchen wir
diese weiche noch ja und natürlich ist
es so dass sich der Güterverkehr auch in
der Struktur verändert und man hat also
viele weich rausgenommen die man nicht
mehr brauchte an manchen Stellen nach
meiner Sicht durch das nachvollziehbar
aber an einigen Stellen muss man das
heutiger Sicht sagen das war falsch ist
das eine der Gründe warum wir diese
vielen Verspätungen sehen nein das ist
glaube ich nicht der Hauptpunkt also der
da geht es eben darum dass man das Netz
massiv verschlankt hat man hat ja auch
jahrelang Nebenstrecken eingestellt muss
im fairerweise sagen wenn da keiner mehr
fährt es gibt Strecken die weit von den
Ortschaften entfernt liegen oder wo ist
ein güterverkehrskunden gab der vor 20
Jahren geschlossen hat er macht doch
keinen Sinn mehr eine Strecke dort zu
haben das war und wenn und wenn jetzt
jetzt steht dieser verspätete oder
dieser Zug steht es im Bahnhof rum und
fährt aus irgendeinem Grund nicht es ist
dann wenn sie so diese Struktur
beschreiben ist es dann klar wer dafür
verantwortlich ist kann man das klar
benennen sollte man eigentlich klar
benennen können es gibt ein System mit
dem das ganze kodiert werden soll das
wird immer gesagt dass da manche
geschummelt wird weil es natürlich
unterschiedliche Gründe gibt und wir
haben auch unterschiedliche
Gesellschaften die tatsächlich Züge
fahren und das ist sozusagen der
Betreiber der den Lokführer nicht
rechtzeitig bringt mal ist es die
Infrastruktur die nicht funktioniert
aber eigentlich wird es kodiert und
eigentlich wird das also auch erfasst
und abgerechnet mancher bei der vorher
verhoben dass der ein oder beim Codieren
mogelt aber im Prinzip wird sowas
erfasst und man kann es verfolgen okay
und welche Verantwortung trägt der
Verkehrsminister ein bisschen von dem
ich manchmal denke der arme Kerl muss
jetzt alles reparieren und da kommt doch
her teurer gleich ins Spiel der muss das
dann umsetzen was da über Jahrzehnte
liegen geblieben ist also welchen
Einfluss hat der Verkehrsminister
wirklich an dem Punkt ähm er hat
natürlich schon eine ganze Menge
Einfluss er ist nicht alleine wir haben
also ein Bundestag ein
Haushaltsgesetzgeber aber muss schon
sagen dass die letzten Verkehrsminister
fast alle seit der Bahn Reformen dass
die ihren Job mehr oder weniger lustlos
gemacht hatten also es gab ja kaum
jemanden der vorher schon mal was mit
Verkehrsmittel zu tun hatte seine
Ausnahme der als Landesminister immer
das schon mal hatte das Thema und
der dann im Unternehmen nachher auch
einen guten Job gemacht hat
ja das höre ich immer so also genau das
ist sicherlich so und
aber man hat sich eben immer nicht darum
gekümmert
und man hat ja die Mittel für den neuen
Ausbau der Schiene vor etwa 20 Jahren
massiv gekürzt das waren mal vier
Milliarden dann ist man auf 1,5
Milliarden runtergegangen
vier Milliarden pro Jahr 4 Milliarden
pro Jahr vor wie viel Jahren vor 20
Jahren und heute ähm jetzt ist mal
wieder bei 2 Milliarden angekommen und
er teurer kämpft dafür dass es wieder
ein bisschen mehr wird aber wir waren
das heißt wenn wir hören wir investieren
jetzt deutlich mehr dann ist es ja noch
nicht mal die Hälfte dessen was wir mal
investiert haben ja es gibt noch andere
Töpfe das wird dann schnell ein bisschen
komplizierter
gesagt das ist deutlich weniger und
deswegen sind also viele Strecken die
man vor 20 Jahren hätte bauen müssen
sind die eben liegen geb das ist
sozusagen für den Ersatz für den für den
Satz Investition das muss ja auch
bestehende Netz etwas machen
da haben sich eben auch Rückstände
angestaut da gibt es seit 15 Jahren ein
Vertrag zwischen Bund und DB AG dass die
Bund ein Teil dass der Bund ein Teil
davon finanziert und jahrelang haben
Ministerium und DB behauptet das sei
alles prima und jetzt gerade seit drei
Monaten sagte die DB ja nicht mehr es
sei alles prima sondern dass er sagt wir
haben es auch gemerkt das ist ganz
furchtbar ist und da gibt es also gerade
eine deutliche Änderung des narratives
und damit muss ich dann jetzt das
Ministerium eben auch herumschlagen
jahrelang liegen lassen okay so jetzt
hier der arme Herr teurer und sagt den
interessanten Satz bei der Bahn muss
alles erst noch viel schlimmer werden
bevor es besser wird was meinen Sie
damit
den Satz habe ich gesagt bevor ich zum
schienenverkehrsbeauftragten
da hatte ich eine Vorahnung als junger
Oberbürgermeister einer Bahnstadt kannte
ich auch diese Gespräche mit großen
runden zur Revitalisierung von Bahn und
Post war also kurz um wir wussten ja
dass in der Infrastruktur da einiges im
Augenblick aber auf seine Jungs Bedarf
investitionsrückstände Straße auf
Schiene aber das ist so schlimm ist
wussten sie nicht ich habe eine
schonungslose Bestandsaufnahme
eingefordert und ich bin ja froh dass
der neue infrastrukturvorstand Huber so
eine generalinventur gemacht hat und das
jetzt also es ist aber unübersehbar
65% Pünktlichkeit im Fernverkehr die
schlechtesten Werte seid eigentlich
immer ich glaube nur vor zehn Jahren was
anderes schlecht also der
Handlungsbedarf ist da eine Meter und
hat sich beklagt über wie viel Prozent
ich hoffe dass 85 sowas ich hoffe dass
sie mich jetzt nicht für Metern
Verantwortlichen
in Großkonzern nicht erfolgreich war nur
in seiner eigenen Firma die nach ihm
benannt ist weil er sich da nicht ins
operative Geschäft eingemischt hat aber
Spaß beiseite
also wir haben uns dazu
sagen was ist und und zu machen was geht
und es gibt instandsetzungs Rückstände
und es gibt ein Sanierungsstau und den
wollen wir anpacken es hatte mein
Minister klar erklärt und auch der
Vorstandsvorsitzende Lutz ja das heißt
jetzt Korridor Sanierung
Generalsanierung des höchst belasteten
Netzes also wie viele wie viele
Baustelle in den nächsten Jahren wo sie
komplett dicht machen also die sind
diesen diesen nennt man das
ja nee die was setzte was jetzt geplant
ist das macht man nicht mehr das wird
man auch noch machen müssen bei den
Strecken wo es keine um rettungsstrecken
gibt aber diese Sanierung unter dem
rollenden Radius
er ist natürlich auch ist immer
schwierig weil die Sperrpausen die dann
eingerichtet werden kurz sind und bis
die Baustelle eingerichtet ist dann
dauert es und dann ist es bei Nacht und
am Wochenende und da kriegt man immer
schwieriger auch Fachkräfte weil die
jungen Leute das ja auch so nicht mehr
machen wollen also kurz um
Generalsanierung Korridor Sperrung vor
fünf Monate das wird fünf Monate sind
das also es sollen 45 Strecken bis 20 30
saniert werden die erste ist die
Riedbahn zwischen Frankfurt und Mannheim
Walddorf die soll im zweiten Halbjahr 24
saniert werden und für 5 Monate machen
Sie einfach zu die Bahn als zuständiges
Eisenbahn Infrastrukturunternehmen wird
zu machen und da wird es entscheidend
darauf ankommt damit wir die Kundinnen
und Kunden nicht verlieren dass es ein
gut funktionieren entschieden
Ersatzverkehr gibt und Umleitung
Strecken für den Güterverkehr also
Ärger ist vorprogrammiert ist klar und
trotzdem machen sie an 45 Orten in ganz
Deutschland zur Sanierung dieses Netzes
keine Alternative weil heute die Zahl
der Störungen in Stellwerken am Gleisbau
in der Oberleitung ein Signalen so
häufig ungeplant zufällig auftreten dass
immer mehr Ressourcen in trouble
Management trappelshooting gesteckt
werden muss und da ist wie im Haus im
Privatbereich die Generation dann
notwendig er wird gern
wie würden sie es machen also ich meine
wie kriegt man das denn so schnell in
den Griff wir wollten doch den
Deutschland Takt und wann wollten wir
den haben 2030 mal jetzt verspäten wir
uns um wie viele Jahrzehnte
ja also diese diese
Jahrzehnte Zahl der teurer neulich
genannt hat das sagt man wir reden jetzt
von 2017
Frage also ich habe mir ja große
Verdienste erworben den deutschlandtakt
bekannter zu machen
wenn das der Plan war der ist
aufgegangen mit diesem Interview also
kurz um
Bedarfsplan steht stehen Maßnahmen und
dahinter steht eine Investitionssumme
und wenn man das zusammenrechnet und
durch die Zahl teilen die zur Verfügung
steht kann man auch auf eine Jahreszahl
kommen also Fakt ist also die Schweizer
dieses schon mal vorgemacht haben mit
dem integralen Taktfahrplan der für den
deutschlandtakt Modell steht die Hand
dafür auch Jahrzehnte gebraucht und wir
werden auch Jahrzehnte brauchen bis
alles fertig ist aber die ersten Etappen
kommen Gott sei Dank früher in 50 Jahren
werden wir soweit sein nein früher also
früher werden schon ist alles läuft
läuft
2030 und die Etappen des
deutschlandtaktes im halben Stundentakt
ab in Betriebnahme des digitalen Knotens
in Stuttgart da ist dann schon eine
halbe Stunden Tag zwischen Köln
Frankfurt Mannheim Stuttgart Ulm und
München möglich und dann von München
okay auch Richtung Berlin er war ganz
kurze Frage ist dass dieses neue
deutschlandtempo von dem Olaf Scholz im
Gespräch
wir haben ein unbestreitbares Problem
das müssen wir wegarbeiten das wird sich
nicht durch fromme Wünsche oder durch
irgendwelche Zaubersprüche beseitigen
lassen also muss man da jetzt durch und
man kann eine Menge lernen daraus ziehen
was ist also vor 20 Jahren schief
gegangen ja welche Strategien sind
damals verfolgt worden die man heute als
hochschiedlich bezeichnen muss Stichwort
Börsengang der damals sozusagen auf
einmal zum größten Ziel der Deutschen
Bahn erklärt wurde das war einfach ein
fataler Fehler und aber jetzt ist es so
wie es ist die Ostfriesen und das dann
wieder vor der Mitte deswegen müssen wir
jetzt durch oh mein Gott
stimmt das dass teilweise noch
Infrastruktur aus der Dampflok
das ist ein gutes Zeichen es ist eine
robuste Infrastruktur die gut
funktioniert und
ich meine es gibt Schweine der
Infrastruktur die werden auch für 100
Jahre gebaut und die halten auch 100
Jahre das alleine ist eben noch kein
Problem aber wir haben natürlich heute
eine ganz andere betriebsdichte als man
das damals hat und Teil der
Unpünktlichkeit des Netzes das muss halt
auch sagen hängt natürlich auch damit
zusammen dass das Netz immer mehr
nachgefragt ist ja und also je mehr Züge
sie eben raufpacken auf ein bestehendes
Netz desto mehr bekommen Sie natürlich
ein Kapazitätsproblem und das ist das
was er im Kern merkt und die abnehmende
Pünktlichkeit hat eigentlich auch damit
zu tun dass die Bahn in den letzten
Jahren durchaus gut gewirtschaftet hat
insofern dass man sagt wir haben mehr
Fahrgäste heute wir haben mehr Güte auf
der Schiene als noch vor einigen Jahren
aber wir haben die Infrastruktur eben
nicht mitgebaut und jetzt kommt der
Punkt
diese seltsame Widersprüchlichkeit die
vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutet habe
erklären Sie sich die also dieses
diamantra dass man gerne in Berlin hört
sagt die Schiene müssen wir ausbauen und
jetzt geht's los und so weiter seit zehn
Jahren erzählen wir uns das und
gleichzeitig wurden die Investitionen in
die Infrastruktur immer kleiner und es
wurde immer schlimmer und immer
schlechter also warum dieser gigantische
Unterschied zwischen reden und duing
ich glaube Investitionen die Schiene
sind nicht besonders populär es bedeutet
eben dass man irgendwo bauen muss und
dann hat man eben Ärger mit Anwohnern
und keine visionäre Politik
Entschuldigung nein nee und vielleicht
ich kann das als Außenpolitik Betrieben
auch sagen dass unser
eine andere Politiker drückt sich dann
eben auch mal weg von Themen die
unangenehm sind und wenn sich mal
angucken sowas wie jetzt das 49 Euro
Ticket das kostet an die 5 Milliarden
Euro pro Jahr ja mit einem vermutlich
sehr geringen verkehrlichen nutzen da
hat haben sie Bund und Länder ja
ganz schnell ganz schnell fünf
Milliarden eben aufgetrieben pro Jahr ja
klar das ist uns die Sache wert und
während man eben wirklich bei den zwei
Milliarden für neuen Ausbau immer am
Kämpfen ist für jeden 100 Millionen Mark
Schein extra und aber das ist eben eine
Sache die kurzfristig populär ist und da
springen dann Politiker eben auch lieber
drauf als ebenso diese dicken Bretter
bohren ich glaube das ist sicherlich ein
Problem des politischen Systems ich will
eigentlich kein Bashing machen aber
der Anreiz Infrastrukturprojekte
anzuschieben die vielleicht erst fertig
sind wenn man selber nicht mehr im Amt
ist der ist natürlich erstmal auch nicht
so groß also ist Deutschland Tickets an
der Stelle so schlecht zu machen bin ich
nicht gut weil das ist wirklich das ist
ein Quantensprung das ist eine
Revolution und zwar vor allen Dingen
weil es das Bahn fahren und Bus und Bahn
fahren so viel einfacher macht keine
Tarifzone keine verbundgrenzen die
Pendler die vorher in drei
Verkehrsverbünden in Abo zahlen mussten
die können jetzt mit einem Ticket fahren
mit 1, fünf Milliarden zur hälftigen
Finanzierung und gleichzeitig auch noch
die Regionalisierungsmittel die eh schon
bei 10 Milliarden Lehrern
ganz wichtig ist
da darf kein Gegensatz sein zwischen
einem Flatrate Ticketing wie wir es
jetzt machen hoch attraktiv und der
Erhöhung der Mittel für die
Infrastrukturen das haben wir ja
glücklicherweise auch im
Koalitionsausschuss und darüber habe ich
mir am meisten gefreut auf dem Weg
gebracht 45 Milliarden Euro bis 2027
sollen ist beschlossen in die Schiene
fließen das ist doch ein richtiger es
ist doch ein richtiges Wort eine
Verdoppelung im Grunde genommen der
Mittel die bisher zur Verfügung stehen
mal ganz kurz für die Investition stimmt
es dass in der Schweiz pro Einwohner pro
Jahr ungefähr 400 € umgerechnet in die
Bahn fließen es kann da also
interessante Zahlen Deutschland ungefähr
100 Euro
aber Faktor 4 stimmt
veröffentlicht 400 Euro zu 124 Euro der
Unterschied so aber in Deutschland waren
es ja noch vor ein paar Jahren nur 60
Euro
verdoppelt es macht auch nicht besser
auch die Vorgängerregierung hat ja schon
angefangen gegenzusteuern aber das sind
wir ja genau beim Punkt ich plädiere als
schienenverkehrsbeauftragter der
Bundesregierung dafür dass wir ein
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Konsens
erreichen wie in der Schweiz weil dieses
System Schiene erfordert langfristiges
Denken und haben sie doch oder nicht
nein also theoretisch ja also auf diese
abstrakten Ebene wenn man sagt irgendwie
mehr Schiene das würden alle
unterstützen wenn man also sagt das
bedeutet aber das gegebenenfalls in der
Nähe von Soltau eben auch neue Gleise
entstehen sollen dann bricht dieser
Konsens sehr schnell zusammen und wir
sehen also dass eben der Widerstand
gegen
Infrastruktur des betrifft ja nicht
betrifft Straße die Stromtrassen über
die wir eben gesprochen haben trifft ja
genauso das also die Bereitschaft
Infrastruktur zu akzeptieren eben sehr
gering ist dieses Thema Soltau ist ein
sehr interessantes Thema in dem
Zusammenhang finde ich ne da geht um die
Strecke Hamburg Hannover ja chronische
überlastet auch einen riesiger Standort
Nachteil der irgendwann Hamburg daraus
erwächst weil alles was im Hamburger
Hafen ankommt kann nicht sozusagen
vernünftig weg transportiert werden Herr
weit kommt auch nicht wirklich nach
Hause deswegen ist er vorsichtshalber
heute mit dem Auto an versteht das und
sie sagen die selben Politiker die in
Berlin im Bund
fordern Ausbau der Schiene kämpfen dann
zu Hause dafür dass die Schiene aber
bitte nicht jetzt bei Ihnen zu Hause
verlegt wird wie geht diese Geschichte
also es wird ja seit 30 Jahren gekämpft
seit 30 Jahren steht diese Neubaustrecke
Hamburg Hannover oder eigentlich
Hamburg-Bremen Hannover 30 seit 30
Jahren im Bundesverkehrswegeplan 1992
das erste Mal drin so ähm
zum einen immer kein Geld gehabt dann
hat man so lustlos geplant weil er
gesagt was soll der Plan Geld ist
sowieso nicht da und ähm dann gab es
eben auch Streit um die Trassen und es
gab es in dem Fall beides SPD
Abgeordnete gewesen es gab also eine aus
Zelle die also in der Verkehrspolitik
ist sehr einflussreich war die gesagt
hat wir brauchen eine neue Strecke aber
doch bitte nicht in Celle und jetzt
haben wir in einer sehr einflussreichen
SPD Politiker der dafür brauchen diese
Strecke aber bitte nicht in Soltau also
es gibt sozusagen
zwei Trassen die sozusagen da im in der
politischen Debatte gerade eine Rolle
spielen also
Software das könnten wir leicht werden
die wissen alle die Geschichte ist
natürlich sehr schön Dinge liegen schon
ein bisschen komplizierter aber ich
erzähle gleich meine Version gelingt
unbedingt aber das ist natürlich der
Punkt also das sind jetzt nicht die
einzigen in dem Fall kann man sagen es
geht es um Niedersachsen
berühmter spd-parteivorsitzenden ja
[Musik]
natürlich hat auch jeder Abgeordneter
die Pflichten die Interessen seines
Wahlkreis zu vertreten das muss ja sehen
so funktioniert
so und an anderen Stellen da hat man
sich dann entschieden im Deutschen
Bundestag statt einer oberirdischen
Güterverkehr Strecke in Tunnel zu bauen
das hat dann auch manchmal einfach
richtig und die Menschen zu schützen und
deshalb wird die Akzeptanz und es zeigt
mir aber dass es sich lohnt und und
gerade bei der Strecke Hannover Hamburg
das sind wir ja in der Phase wo die DB
als vorhabenträgerinnen im
Planungsprozess ist und der ist doch gar
nicht abgeschlossen da auch noch einige
Fragen die zu lösen sind aber die Frage
der Akzeptanz die stellt sich nicht nur
bei Hamburg Hannover sondern eigentlich
bei jeder Strecke denn am Sonntag sagen
die Menschen Güter auf die Bahn aber
Montag bis Samstag sind sie gegen die
güterverkehrsstrecke ja ja und ich hätte
jetzt folgende Frage auch weil sie
teurer sagte gerade so so nebenbei den
schönen Satz da sind doch einige Fragen
zu lösen seit 30 Jahren versuchen wir
diese Fragen ja das kommt sehr darauf an
also es ging die Geschichte geht
tatsächlich vor 35 Jahren los noch
schlimmer seit 35 Jahren wird darüber
diskutiert wird geplant wird Geld
ausgegeben und es ist buchstäblich
nichts passiert das war am Anfang einer
andere Trasse die sogenannte Y-Trasse so
nach 35 Jahren ja mit Hamburg und Bremen
und Hannover
nach 35 Jahren wird die Deutsche Bahn
was ich absolut richtig fand das
Handtuch und sagt leute lasst uns
aufhören an dieser Stelle wir brauchen
was neues weil auf die Art und Weise
wird es eben nichts ne gehen wir nur
Geld raus die ganzen Kostenkalkulationen
stimmen alle sowieso nicht mehr so was
machen wir jetzt daraufhin haben wir in
Niedersachsen damals als Landespolitik
unser Verkehrsminister Olaf ließ der ist
jetzt auch wieder ist in einem mühsamen
Prozess gesagt naja gut jetzt die Bahn
sagt das wird jetzt nichts dann müssen
wir irgendeine Alternative haben es kann
ja nicht alles so bleiben wie es jetzt
ist und haben wirklich Gemüse Samstag
Kleinarbeit gesagt können wir nicht die
bestehenden Strecken so aufwerten dass
wir wesentlich mehr Verkehr
transportieren können das ist
wahrscheinlich nicht die top top Lösung
aber es ist
eine wesentliche Verbesserung gegenüber
dem Status Quo das wird werden sie auch
zustimmen das ist eine also ich habe
mich auch im Vorfeld noch mal mit
wirklichen Fachleuten auch gesprochen
die sich damit auskennen die sagen nein
diese Lösung ist Quatsch es gibt jede
Menge Ärger es gibt ja auch Städte
Berlin
gibt's überall das haben Recht gesagt
aber wenn ich eine Lösung habe ja das
ist wenn Sie so wollen ich glaube auf
dem Dach ist der Gedanke ich baue jetzt
endlich mal hier geradeaus durch und das
würde ich schon spazieren und in
Wirklichkeit ist es kein Spatz aber es
ist auch nicht gerade die Taube kein
großer Vogel jedenfalls eine wesentliche
Verbesserung
es ist ein klein bisschen eine
Verbesserung wobei der
Bürgermeister von Lüneburg wird zu
diesem Veranstaltungen immer nicht mehr
eingeladen weil der eine andere Meinung
hat das ist eine Strecke genau durch
Lüneburger Bürgermeisterin und zweitens
hat die kräftig mit diskutiert als bei
dem Thema ich glaube sie waren
Mitarbeiter neulich in Berlin diskutiert
wurde also keine Sorge die Demokratie
zählt an dieser Stelle nach wie vor
häufig hinaus werden
überhaupt nichts zu tun kein Abgeordnete
des Deutschen Bundestages hätte eine
Chance
so etwas zu verhindern wenn ansonsten
die Dinge alle klar werden sind sie aber
nicht und wir gehen in Wirklichkeit
wieder ganz zurück auf den Nullpunkt und
wenn man das vermeiden will der muss man
mindestens das jetzt machen was man
machen kann ist eigentlich das aller
mindeste oder wollen wir das tatsächlich
in 70 Jahren dann vielleicht
irgendein okay